je vais te poser des questions au sujet
des missions de personnalité cette fois
tu vas devoir cracher dans la soupe
d'accord tu peux laisser Jean-Marc le
faire
dis-moi Jeff tu es souvent venu dans
TPMP tu prends toujours autant de
plaisir à venir
et bien je prends
toujours autant d'argent pour venir déjà
et puis non enfin moi j'en ai plein le
cul en fait de venir voilà ça fait 10
piges que je viens ici pour débriefer
l'amour dans le pré donc
voilà et puis on me dit ah qu'est-ce que
tu penses de Benjamin Castaldi alors
c'est tout ce que personne n'en pensait
rien donc voilà
pas réussi il est fort
Patrick Sébastien va venir dans un
instant c'est lui qui t'a lancé c'est un
chiffre
c'est un chic type non Patrick
un chic type
déjà
enfin moi j'ai passé trois piges à faire
le con entre entre un trapéziste et un
clone donc franchement vu j'étais obligé
de faire semblant d'être d'être complice
avec lui donc moi j'en ai marre quoi
Jean-Marc
des conneries il va faire du buzz
Sébastien il va venir là dans un instant
c'est pour ça que je l'adore
l'énergie musicale c'est vraiment une
belle cérémonie pour les artistes
[Rires]
c'est une belle galère surtout voilà
parce qu'on sait tous que quand on passe
pas sur NRJ bah on est en pot de fleur
dans le public donc voilà et puis
surtout pour les humoristes c'est une
belle place de merde voilà tu peux le
dire tout à fait des [__] il y a
vraiment que des artistes sympas dans la
troupe une bonne ambiance
ben oui
non c'est une belle brochette de
connards
pas très bien et moi en plus finir
déguiser en géranium et chanter avec
Yann folie et franchement je vous
embrasse
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis désolé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je l'adore il y a non non
l'émission de Michel Drucker c'est ton
émission préférée non
faut que je dise du mal de Michel
Drucker
Michel faut qu'il arrête quoi
le canapé c'est affaissé et pas que le
canapé
ça te fait quoi de voir autant de stars
internationales se prêter au jeu de
cette émission
[Rires]
il est sous contrat en fait des
conneries
international de 1992 et c'est
cool il y avait David
toi ta première télé ce que tu t'en
rappelles on la met à chaque fois on la
met à chaque fois j'adore mais on la
mettra pas cette fois
non non tu te rappelles ou pas qu'elle
anesthé tu avais 11 ans pas du tout mais
on va pas la remettre non tu chantais
c'est bon la vue sans toi
franchement en plus
il paraît que tu aurais nommé Jean-Marc
en hommage au patron du magasin de magie
que tu fréquentais quand tu étais petit
j'étais gamin et un jour j'ai voulu
commencer la ventriloquet et j'ai trouvé
Jean-Marc dans la dans la vitrine comme
dans un autre pays où faut payer pour ça
et voilà je suis tombé en amour pour
pour lui et le patron du magasin de
magie s'appelait Jean-Marc je dis bah je
vais l'appeler Jean-Marc pour toi et tu
étais un ancien électricien ouais bah tu
sais que tu es tu vas peut-être
reprendre l'électricité parce qu'il y en
aura plus je veux dire qu'il y aura du
boulot oui mais on est on va s'y atteler
et c'est bon c'est Patrick Sébastien qui
t'a repéré dans le bureau cabaret dans
un instant mais comment est-ce qu'il y a
des cours de ventriloqués est-ce qu'il y
a des mecs qui font travailler ah bah
moi non à personne ça se voit d'ailleurs
j'ai trouvé ça comme ça voilà Jeff futur
je te pose la question je sais pas parce
que ça me rend fou moi comment on se
rencontre qu'on arrive à faire ça
comment tu le fais la première fois en
fait on déconne avec des potes et puis
tes potes te dire ah t'arrive bien à le
faire et puis après on se dit bah tiens
si on a des travailler dans des cabarets
comme c'est hyper moderne tu as
découvert ça à quel âge j'avais 15 15 16
ans et un moment tu peux intitulé tu es
arrivé à parler sans c'est ouf c'est un
beau tableau
[Applaudissements]